quanti di voi hanno visto il film
minoriti report per chi non l'avesse
visto il film racconta di un futuro
distopico in cui la polizia in grado di
prevedere il crimine prima che questo
avvenga ora in realtà non ci siamo molto
lontani
già dal 2016 la polizia di chicago
utilizza un software in grado di dare un
punteggio ad ogni cittadino
in questo modo sono in grado di
prevedere quali quartieri della città
sono più pericolosi o qual è il crimine
che più probabile avvenga abbastanza
inquietante o almeno la domanda che mi
viene è giusto che sia una macchina a
schedarci in base non so a quale
quartiere siamo nati
qual è il nostro ceto sociale qual è il
colore della nostra pelle
ora quello che ci aspetta davanti
sicuramente è un grosso problema di
etica di morale se per un attimo
pensiamo che già per noi è difficile
dare un significato le parole etica
morale saper dire cosa è giusto e
sbagliato
immaginate quanto può essere difficile
trasmettere questi valori a un computer
a un calcolo matematico quello che ci ha
insegnato la fantascienza e che dobbiamo
ottenere delle macchine che un giorno si
possano ribellare ai loro creatori
ma nella realtà non dobbiamo temere
macchine che abbiano uno scopo
dobbiamo ottenere delle macchine che
hanno uno scopo che non sia in linea con
il nostro missili a guida autonoma una
cosiddetta arma intelligente ha uno
scopo ben preciso
il problema è quanto quello scopo siamo
noi oppure
macchina guida autonoma nel momento in
cui deve decidere se per salvare la vita
di un pedone può sacrificare la vita del
guidatore o viceversa
sta facendo una precisa scelta morale e
quella morale le abbiamo insegnato a noi
a tal proposito vorrei citarvi il
pensiero di alcuni importanti scienziati
ad esempio stephen hawking aveva
previsto che semmai semmai fossimo
riusciti ad arrivare ad avere
l'intelligenza artificiale completa
questa sarebbe finita per essere un
pericolo per la nostra stessa civiltà o
ancora elon musk fondatore di spaces e
tesla che di recente ha immaginato
scenari ancora più apocalittici in cui
l'uomo diventa schiavo di queste nuove
macchine pensanti entrambi insieme a 98
altri scienziati nel 2015 hanno firmato
una petizione alle nazioni unite
chiedendo di mettere al bando l'utilizzo
dell'intelligenza artificiale nella
creazione di queste nuove armi quello
che loro temono a una nuova corsa agli
armamenti soprattutto dei conflitti su
più larga scala quello che temono quindi
è che un giorno noi arriveremo ad avere
delle intelligenza artificiale delle
macchine molto più intelligenti di noi e
quindi noi finiremo per esserne schiavi
quello che evidenziano è un problema
molto spesso sottovalutato dalla ricerca
scientifica e cioè la velocità con cui
questa tecnologia sta avanzando vi
faccio un esempio si pensa che l'essere
umano sia arrivato ad acquisire la
parola in ventimila anni nel 2014
google ha realizzato un progetto alf ago
quindi un computer che è stato in grado
di imparare a giocare ago questo gioco
da solo
in meno di un anno
è sempre meno di un anno è stato in
grado di battere li sito quello che è
stato per 18 volte il campione del mondo
la vera differenza quindi è che mentre
noi siamo legati alla nostra evoluzione
biologica a un computer
noi oggi dobbiamo fargli fare qualcosa
li dobbiamo impartire delle istruzioni
ben precise lo dobbiamo programmare gli
dobbiamo dire cosa deve fare
l'intelligenza artificiale invece è
capace di trovare da sola le risposte a
un problema quindi più va avanti la
tecnologia più velocemente
queste macchine saranno in grado di
trovare soluzioni più efficienti
io personalmente sono affascinato dalle
mille nuove prospettive che questa
tecnologia sta portando nelle nostre
nuove vite
immaginate per esempio gli assistenti
vocali che avete sul vostro smartphone
macchine a guida autonoma ai videogiochi
per quella che è la mia esperienza in
questo settore
faccio un po fatica ad immaginare
l'essere umano che diventi schiavo di
queste nuove macchine senzienti
di sicuro esiste anche un problema
morale e sociale legato a questa
tecnologia
se pensiamo che tesla sta mettendo
appunto dei tir per il ritiro guida
autonoma per il trasporto delle merci
questo probabilmente renderà più sicuro
le nostre autostrade ma al costo di
quanti posti di lavoro
il termine intelligenza artificiale o
cervelli elettronici
sicuramente ci fa volare con la fantasia
ma dobbiamo pur sempre ricordare che
stiamo parlando di statistica di analisi
di dati di problem solving
insomma
tutta roba abbastanza più noiosa
rispetto a quello che ci ha insegnato
terminator
quello che mi piacerebbe veder
realizzato quindi è stato condotto un
esperimento scienziati provenienti da
germania francia stati uniti hanno
raccolto delle fotografie di alcuni
melanomi hanno chiesto un pool di medici
di diagnosticare che tipo di melano
maira partendo da queste fotografie
quale fosse la terapia più corretta ora
immaginate che in questo pool di medici
è riuscito a trovare la terapia giusta
nell 86 per cento dei casi una macchina
ci è riuscita nel 95 per cento dei casi
o ancora di recente ho avuto il piacere
di collaborare con una giovane startup
di rimini che ha brevettato un nuovo
sistema per prevenire bear strikes
per chi non lo sapesse borsa yccs quando
uno stormo di uccelli colpisce un aereo
in fase di decollo atterraggio
non so se vi ricordate nel 2009 c'è
stato il famoso incidente per cui un
aereo di linea dovuto ammarare nel fiume
hudson
quell'incidente fu causato proprio da un
burst rex che distrusse entrambi i
motori è quell incidente sarebbe potuto
costare la vita a 190 persone solo la
bravura del pilota permise di portare
tutti in salvo
secondo i dati dell'enac per esempio
solo in italia nel 2014 si sono
registrati più di 300 incidenti per un
costo totale di 40 milioni di euro
vi posso assicurare da da pilota di
ultraleggeri che l'idea di andare a
sbattere contro un oggetto che può
generare mezza tonnellata di forza è
qualcosa che mi terrorizza quello che
invece è riuscito a realizzare questa
startup è un sistema in grado di
studiare in movimento degli uccelli
intorno all'aeroporto trovarne quali
sono i pattern e quindi capire in
anticipo quando questi rischiano di
essere un pericolo per gli aerei che
stanno movimentando quindi quello che io
mi immagino è questo una tecnologia che
sia di supporto al genio dell'essere
umano
io personalmente mi occupo di sviluppo
software sono nato e cresciuto nella
cultura degli anni 80 quindi mi parlò di
pacman tetris ritorno al futuro
erano era l'era degli 8 bit
eppure oggi sono qui su questo palco e
vi sto parlando di un cervello
elettronico che è capace di
diagnosticare un tumore partendo da una
fotografia
voglio dire non sarò l'unico
elettrizzato
quindi quello che ci aspettava avanti
una grossa sfida il tempo sta correndo
velocemente oggi dobbiamo saperci dare
una risposta su come questa tecnologia
può esserci d'aiuto senza finirne per
diventare schiavi come trovare in modo
per cui questa tecnologia sia l'aiuto al
genio dell'essere umano
in definitiva sarà questo quello che ci
renderà schiavi o sarà il gradino che ci
porterà verso le stelle
[Applauso]